une activité insolite à lille de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines une session
le disc golf était proposé gratuitement
dans la structure ce samedi 24 octobre
ce sport très populaire aux états-unis
en australie est un mélange entre
l'ultimate et le golf
on va être sur des règles très similaire
à celle du golfe avec un parcours qui va
aller de 4 comme aujourd'hui panier à 18
paniers potentiellement et l'objectif
c'est d'envoyer le frisbee dans le
panier en faisant le moins de lancers
possible leur partant à chaque fois de
landreau le frisbee et ont joué en
compétition par cinq cent mille
personnes à travers le monde et 22 clubs
en france cette activité peut être
également pratiqué au niveau loisir
comme ce jour là à travers quatre trous
on est sur une activité très ludique
très convivial et accessible à tous à
partir moment effectivement où on peut
parcourir la distance entre les
différents paniers c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui va être ouvert à tous
les publics un peu comme le golf
finalement après une heure de pratique
première réaction c'est intéressant de
découvrir le golf après vers le frisbee
et donc tous les enfants devront
apprécier donc du coup c'est une
activité sans pratiquer un même niveau
de thibaut elle dernier à à 5 ans a
réussi à faire donc on est content bien
mais au bout d'un moment là bas j'étais
juste devant j'ai lancé et à cause du
vent s'est emporté j'ai pas pu réussir
on est devant on fait une activité en
famille on peut se balader faire
approuver un petit peu d'adressé
agréable l'île des loisirs organisera de
nouvelles sessions de disc-golf dans les
prochains mois et notamment pendant la
période estivale